it is predominantly about crime and
predominantly about the fact that we
have wanton crime throughout every
single major metro area in the United
States homicides are still up over
pre-pandemic levels this is largely
because of depolicing that has come on
the heels of the racial Reckoning uh in
the wake of George Floyd and you can
look at every stat you can look at it
from homicide rates to traffic
fatalities that go up in the immediate I
mean within days of George Floyd's death
to the point where you know you've got
the mayor of Minneapolis is out there
twerking this week twerking in the
street uh we could just see if we find
the clip at some point but this is what
Jacob fry is doing out there in the
meantime his city has seen homicides
explode to 1990s levels so when I say
get out of cities I mean get out of
cities so that your family can live